i'm a shepherd
ensuring the everlasting life of human
beings is my priority
so seeing them endangered by the entity
is difficult
i'm deeply worried for their futures
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the finale of raised by wolves
second season happiness is in a weird
position in that there has been no
announcement of a third season yet and
it closed out with somewhat of a
cliffhanger the title relates to what
might be best for humans in this
particular situation on kepler-22b and
i'll be talking about that and how we
got there right after a quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched raised by
wolves season 2 episode 8 yet then this
video won't be for you and with that out
of the way let's get into it the finale
of the second season of raised by wolves
is the kind of episode where a lot of
stuff happens to get us to an ending
that probably negates a lot of its
importance because at the end the
children and the majority of the
colonists are in the process of turning
into those creatures we've seen
inhabiting the planet grandmother is
behind this and she sees it as necessary
for her mission in order to ensure the
everlasting life of human beings she had
to alter the equation make them simpler
happier versions of themselves when they
eventually become more like the sea
creatures and migrate into the water the
entity will return to its slumber the
fact that she removed her veil and
interacted with humans without it for
the first time hasn't yet changed her
mind about them the degradation of the
tropical zone and its electromagnetic
field that protected people from the
signal that originates in the planet's
core created a situation where no one is
safe from the influence of the entity
mother is the only other character
grandmother revealed her plan to and
she's currently locked away in a
simulation inside a hibernation pod on
the tarantula before the veil
incapacitated her and nulled her powers
she did put it together that the
children were being devolved she
observed champion's skin changing him
telling tempest he wished they could go
into the water and the mutations in the
newborn this was all set in motion by
the video game grandmother installed in
the habitation pod and then later
distributed to all the other colonists
through nervous trading post based on
the way that campion seemed to be
welcoming of the changes he was
experiencing it doesn't appear that
grandmother will encounter much
resistance to what's happening even if
the infected figure it out like mother
did they're really no match for the
ancient android you did see that tempest
and father were concerned about mother's
disappearance and really the only
imaginable way they can do something
about what's happening to them is to
find her and free her this is only part
of the story though because what
grandmother isn't even aware of is that
the season ends with a floating marcus
who possibly rose from the dead or
should i say was resurrected after paul
studied sue's research he realized the
signal couldn't be transmitted inside
the tropical zone's emf the tree was the
entity's way of circumventing that
allowing it to weaponize the serpent of
course the veil enabled mother to lure
number seven in with the same lullaby
she sang to a young champion and destroy
it but out of its corpse a new barren
tree emerged this one didn't have any
fruit but it resembled the one that came
from sioux because paul believed that
the signal might be coming from
underground marcus returned to the
temple to try to use the cage to go back
into the pit before he could do that he
was shot by lucius who was being guided
by the voice the entity told him that he
was the real prophet it told him where
marcus would be and what he had to do to
punish him this involves stealing the
ancient mithraic punisher mask and
letting marcus die wearing it after
crucifying him on the tree after he did
that he could take the cage all the way
down inside the pit apparently marcus
only went halfway and in his defense
there was a large serpent skeleton
blocking it the first time he went down
lucius waits for him to die and then
after he checks his pulse to confirm
that he gets ready to leave but he finds
out that things aren't going to turn out
the way he planned he turns to see that
marcus has disappeared and as blood
drips on him from above he looks up to
see him floating there above the ground
it cuts the black before we get any real
information about what's happening as
mentioned it looks as though marcus has
been resurrected possibly he achieved an
upgrade by going through this process
maybe he really is the entity's chosen
one it seems like the voice tells
everyone that if they want to hear it
and you know lucius is pissed right now
maybe the implication is that soul or
the entity or the voice has entered the
body perhaps now marcus is just the host
i'd like to find out what the answer to
this question is but it's only one of
many questions i have about this thing
that apparently resides in the planet's
core it knows things it knew where
marcus would be ahead of time which
means it knew what he would do in the
past it told paul what happened to his
parents on earth it reached out to otho
when he was still on the ark and there's
more but what's important is that these
are not garden variety tricks they all
point to this thing being quite powerful
grandmother says it wants to destroy the
planet but also believes that it'll just
stop trying if the people all go live
inside the acid ocean that and things
like that throw me off and grandmother's
other statement about humans on kepler
spending many centuries trying to answer
that question but ultimately the limits
of their own rationality made it
impossible that doesn't help i think
what continues to work best for this
series is the androids seeing humanity
reflected in their actions is what keeps
me interested just that one degree of
separation vril and grandmother both
turned out to be fascinating new members
of that family and i'd be lying if i
didn't say that i find them so much more
interesting than paul and campion making
mother's parental instinct something
that is built in and things like that
that has a way of shining a light on
things we often overlook in ourselves
and our fellow human beings and there's
plenty of weird and sometimes there's
funny mother reaching into her dying
child's eye and yanking its brain out to
show just how effective the veil is and
on the other end of that grandmother
saying that having it off was unpleasant
but tolerable which you know sounds like
life sometimes there's a kind of comedy
there plus father finally having someone
to laugh at his dad jokes in a vacuum
you love to see it there are some loose
ends out there everyone eating the fruit
seems to be unimportant considering
they're all changing into creatures but
perhaps it might give those who aided a
type of immunity it did come from the
entity and paul and vita both had some
so it might be important when veta found
a smaller dodecahedron with eyes printed
on it it did sound like she was hearing
a voice that could be related to the
fruit or it could just be that the emf
was breaking down campion preserves some
of the original vril's writing and even
though paul wrote it off as dopey earth
stuff it's bound to be important or
maybe what will be important is that he
was hoping it was something and it
wasn't mother made the point to him that
androids don't die they just break down
which might mean that there's a path for
his virile to come back or maybe number
seven who if you think about it got a
pretty raw deal i know the nursing
rejection scene was supposed to add some
emotion there since mother wasn't able
to follow through before she put on the
veil this is a fierce mother taking the
life of her child it goes against her
nature but what about number seven he
never signed up to be a pawn in seoul's
game
you did get to see what was on the metal
card it showed an ancient human being
turned into a tree like what happened
with sue the cards are being carried
around by a group of humans that are
resisting the de-evolution the cards
appear to be warnings against the relics
that the entity and its followers are or
were spreading around the planet the
ones that have been discovered all seem
to be ancient but it all gets pretty
confusing they were put there by the
believers who fought in a war against
the technocrats who designed grandmother
in her veiled logic to protect those
humans she had to change them and it's
not clear where these resistors came
from initially you've seen a few of them
that were still existing on the planet
trying to warn other humans about the
relics and maybe they weren't worried
about the evolution anymore because
grandma hadn't been around for some time
they created her lost control and then
found a way to neutralize her if that
were the case then why wouldn't they all
just be back in the tropical zone which
you imagine that they created why
wouldn't they go back inside and just
thrive there at some point during the
conflict between the technocrats and the
believers someone decided to try to
colonize earth the mere image of father
and mother coming back to kepler and the
when of that is totally up in the air a
million years is a long time and i don't
think we're that much closer after the
conclusion of this season to really
understand
what came before what we're seeing right
now we're getting bits and pieces but
it's all to say that we don't have
enough information to put together an
explanation depending on your taste
that's not necessarily a bad thing and i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought of the finale what you
thought of this season and your theories
about what's gonna happen if we get a
third please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon